ну вот мы и вернулись во львов и
я с соло Мией, которая моя
учительница украинского языка, а также директор львовской
школы украинского языка и культуры,
а также помните факультет во
львовском национальном университете в  лингвистика,
и поэтому она может помочь
нам со славянскими проблемами в
изучении психических языков, мы будем использовать
русский в качестве примера, все эти
объяснения применимы ко всем славянским
языкам.
Издание, которое у меня
есть, и мне потребовалось много времени, чтобы
разобраться с глаголами совершенного и
несовершенного вида, не могли бы вы помочь мне снова,
как правило, мы используем защитный падеж,
описывающий действие в процессе в
процессе несовершенный находится в процессе правильный
эффективный опишите действие как
результат  в результате пожалуйста печенье
готово готово можете привести несколько примеров
она умерла за то она научила вас
она прикасалась президент Роча читать и
читать по английски а по русски два
разных понятия точно
ага джосия кто подскажет  стс это после
значит я читаю как процесс ладно я
читаю книгу я на 33 странице а я добрался
до страницы 45 йа-тчи шина ключ иди посмотри что
переключается по диагонали да я буду ты
кончил ладно так ты  все в порядке,
как у меня есть мяч Кайба У меня есть книга
об истории св.  Петербург и
Зафра или Ленисе Хорн Авив или Владивосток
или да да
так да Да в голландском стиле можете ли вы сказать другими
словами я намерен прочитать
всю книгу ровно с первой до
второй страницы последняя страница это звучит как
обещание и это обещание это  обязательство
точно хорошо, когда вы будете читать книгу
, после того, как я подошел, я окуни, иду, я
прочитаю книгу, и это будет сделано,
как хороший пример, было бы еще, как это сделать,
и все же это также делать, значит, это
правильно сказать  да, в LRU, да, это
желтый означает, что я участвую в этом.
Фиделис, это означает, что вы даете или незначительное
ужасное
ничего особенно ужасного не даете вам, тогда я
обещаю вам, что сделаю это, когда вы
собираетесь делать свою домашнюю работу
точно нет так знай что это дилеры
машинист без тебя зафар да папа
сигна зафт нет да да я доделаю
закончу процесс
делать свой домашний телевизор на гелии я
перепутал с ней украина мисс джулиан
мисс делеон с желатином
он энни есть  настоящая каша  n dah yah yah
yah yah Люк Джесси Аделио, я в
процессе этого, я имею в виду, я делаю это,
но да, желтый, твой DL, ты, да,
воздух, ты, потому что CLU будет поставлять,
подразумевает, что я закончу это, так что
еще  желтый ты и Роберто
да тележурналист
ха-ха да мы сообщаем о них да мы
отчитываемся перед любым ужасным Энни
ужасные пожилые ребята здесь идеально
охраняют но ловят снова каждый день так что
это процесс мы работаем с нашей работой
каждый день но теперь конечно  префикс
или то, как изменяются глаголы,
будет отличаться для разных глаголов,
но просто для того, чтобы дать вам представление
о разнице между глаголами совершенного и
совершенного вида.
у меня нет этой
концепции, но, честно говоря, это сложно
для русскоговорящих или говорящих по-украински, похоже,
мы были отрезаны там, так что это,
конечно, как вы можете сказать, это еще один день,
и это приближается к концу моего пребывания
в  vivre, к сожалению, да, я
отправляюсь в трехдневный тур по
Карпатам, но для меня львов стал
удивительным открытием, это вроде как
три культуры сходятся вместе, три или
четыре, на самом деле все, в то время как украинский,
очевидно, польский и русский, и даже
немного немецкого, но три основных
славянских языка объединяются, и я
думаю, что в школе украинского языка и
культуры вы на самом деле учите русский
украинский и полируете его правильно,
сильно украинский полируете и русский м-м-м,
и вы говорите через себя о нас,
и вы знаете  мы не должны относиться к таким
особенностям славянских языков, как
глаголы движения и падежи, как к проблемам, они
на самом деле являются положительными чертами
языка, и мы собираемся как-то работать
вместе, да, и у
нас уже есть некоторые идеи, и у нас есть некоторые
идеи о том, как мы можем продолжать, даже когда
я вернусь в Ванкувер, чтобы подготовить
материал по славянским языкам, может быть, для
всех трех языков, которые мы сделаем
доступными для
людей, которые следуют  нас на YouTube и,
конечно, я хочу, чтобы вы взяли на заметку
название школы украинского языка и культуры,
я оставлю ссылку в
карточках описания, любой из вас, какой
замечательный опыт должен прийти в
V и учиться с Солой через после школы
и что я могу сказать, пожалуйста, хорошо,
и и Львов - это большое открытие,
и история города, различные
культурные влияния, а также это
заставляет вас осознать весь этот
восточноевропейский мир, который мы, как правило, не
так много знаем  о Западе, и это
увлекательно, так что вот оно, и
вы услышите от нас большое спасибо,
пока
[Музыка]